some people say there were no real movie
stars anymore I say the wrong ladies and
gentlemen Tom Cruise
at the very first Academy Awards
presentation two Oscars were given for
directing one for drama to Frank or xaj
for seventh Heaven and the other for
comedy to Lewis milestone for two
Arabian Nights
here are five directors whose work
carries on the high standards of
excellence set by their predecessors
over the past century
Kevin Costner for Dances with Wolves
Francis Ford Coppola for The Godfather
Part three Martin Scorsese for good
fellows
Stephen Frears for The Grifters
and Barbet Schroeder for reversal of
fortune and this year the Oscar for
directing goes to Kevin Costner
I didn't trust myself
I don't even when I make the movies I
have to write everything down everyone
knows that you really don't make
pictures by yourself and I accept this
tonight on behalf of my friends people
that influenced my life influenced this
movie Jim Wilson and Michael Blake like
a special things to go out to guy easton
jacob roots and the people at majestic
the same people who came down to mexico
and watched my little slideshow and
tried to figure out through all my
boyish enthusiasm that i was deadly
serious about making this movie like to
thank bill bernstein Mike Medavoy made
two movies with me and allowed me to
direct this third to Michael Ovitz for
his careful reconstruction it helped me
finish dances without having to
compromise my dream and finding out I'd
like to share this award with my wife
Cindy and my three children my brother
and my parents who I'm so happy that
that we are alive to share this together
thank you very much
next the award for best picture of the
year